David, we're getting close to those Georgia
runoffs. Can Joe Biden get anything done if
Democrats don't win Georgia? So this is a
different version of something we've we've
been talking about. If Democrats are unable to
win both of those races, making the Senate a
50 50 tie with Kamala Harris is the tie breaking
vote. I would be shocked if anything substantial
is done from a legislative standpoint. Mitch
McConnell will go back to the Obama playbook,
as I talked about in the last segment, obstruct
everything, offer no bipartisanship, period.
In addition to that, even with winning the
runoffs, there are lots of issues that are
going to be a fight. When you consider I know
it's almost cliche to say, but Joe Manchin from
West Virginia is the most right wing Democratic
senator. There are lots of Biden ideas that I
have a hard time imagining. Joe Manchin goes
for now. Maybe you can find a Republican or two
to go for them, even if Joe Manchin doesn't.
But the next two years will be a very
big uphill battle for Joe Biden legislatively,
regardless of what happens in January in Georgia.
Without those wins, nothing gets done. And
Joe Biden will essentially have to govern by
Pyhrric, compromise where you have to give
up so much in order to get Republicans to
work with you that there's a question as to
whether it's even a worthwhile exchange and
by executive order. Fortunately, Biden can
get a lot of things done by executive order.
And my hope is that what Biden can't do
legislatively in these first two years,
he can do via building goodwill and and sort of
reestablishing the U.S. is respectable globally,
which our global reputation has been in the
toilet, thanks to Donald Trump. But but then, you
know, the. The complicated part, the part where
it gets tough is even with both Senate seats,
what one of the big things, can you actually
get done for some four really major things?
You also need a supermajority which Democrats
with 50 50 and Kamala Harris is the tiebreaker
aren't aren't going to have. They'll be able
to do the budget bill that only needs 50 votes.
They can put some extras in it and see what else
they can get done. That way, they will be able
to confirm Supreme Court justices if Joe Biden
indeed gets to nominate anybody. And, you know,
maybe you can do some infrastructure, maybe you
can do it's just health. Climate and tax reform
seem really, really tough and it's going to be an
uphill battle. So that's that's my perspective at
this point. And then, of course, there's this idea
of do they do they do away with the filibuster?
Divergent opinions on the left about that. Let's
just wait and see what happens January 5th in
Georgia before we have that conversation, because
I think that let's not even waste our breath on
that issue until we know what's going to happen
in the state of Georgia. We have a great bonus
show for you today. And remember, we are off
next week. No new shows next week. Everybody
relax. The show's not canceled. Just an end of
the year break. So bonus show coming up right
after this. Become a member at join Pakman dot com
to get instant access and then nothing next week.
And then back with you on
Monday, January 4th, 2021.